cette question d'actualité à présent
faut-il créer une instance de régulation
pour éviter certains dérapages constatés
récemment sur l'internet ce que
d'information extraordinaire
internet est un espace de liberté quasi
totale sur lequel on trouve de tout même
le pire pédophilie violence ou
incitation à la haine raciale
les professionnels commencent à
s'organiser et la france a même dit en
place d'une telle politique
radiant camelot ce comité cette
publicité vante les mérites du bazar un
site internet où chacun peut vendre aux
enchères les objets dont il n'a plus eu
plusieurs dizaines en permanence un
terrain idéal pour les trafiquants et
les extrémistes en tout genre pour les
décourager l'entreprise emploie cette
version locale et modérateur un nouveau
métier d'internât sauront veiller à ce
que les annonces du site ne propose rien
d'illégal mais aux heures de pointe
il y en a beaucoup trop certaines
passent entre les mailles du filet
vers 12h30 une annonce a été posée était
la rubrique animaux 3-2 juifs avant la
modération à cette heure-là avait
beaucoup de trafic d'objets rodez est
scindé de la transe environ une heure et
magne traduction cette annonce
antisismiques a mis plus d'une heure
avant d'être contrôlé le site enregistre
jusqu'à 10000 connections par heure
impossible de tout vérifier
immédiatement mais une fois détecté la
noce doit être d'écouter quelqu'un nous
signale quelque chose un objet en
l'occurrence pour mon poilu lazare un
objet qui est illicite sur le site et
que nous ne fassions vient là on peut
tenir chaque jour des annonces
pédophiles ou néo nazis sont ainsi
supprimées mais la lutte n'est pas
toujours aussi simple
il est gros fort de rosny sous bois si
une dizaine de gendarmes spécialisés
surveille internet lorsqu'il tombe sur
un site interdit une procédure se met en
route elle peut aboutir à des
interpellations
le site se trouve en france c'est assez
facile n'était qu' on le retrouve à
l'étranger la procédure est complexe il
faut passer par internet interpol
complexe longue et le avoir changé
d'adressé
autre difficulté ce qui est interdit en
france ne l'est pas forcément à
l'étranger du la législation des états
unis le droit d'expression est libre là
bas qu'on a parfaitement le droit des
dieux qu'on est raciste
en france les délits les plus fréquents
sur le net sont les escroqueries et le
trafic de drogue mais là les infractions
sont si nombreuses que parfois la
justice renonce à les poursuivre